that is what the audience or like you
guys like maybe connected with was just
like having people make you feel like
you're not alone out there wherever
you're whatever you're going through
whatever stage you're in it's rain it's
really weird like in the Moment Like if
you really stop and like stop even
thinking about the fact that we're
recording right now like yes as the
seconds go by like we're literally
living the end of this
the dad cries sometimes okay
you think it's always the moms
just a big old soft bead
[Music]
it's a big mood possibly for the last
time what
possibly more likely
we like to be a
our last episode yeah oh man but the
door has a little crack cue the Dr Dre
ready for the last so is it the next
episode
I drink she gave me alcohol I know I'm
ashamed of myself also that was 22 years
ago Google it
I said both versions so I just Casey cut
the one in that I that was right
anyway yeah it's kind of Bittersweet uh
we're all back together again and we're
all on the LA set our oh not our OG set
but you know the OG Hometown yeah
four different states yep what states
Texas Nevada California state of
depression and a state of depression
but now we're all in a state of I'm
actually doing okay
he was happy yeah yeah that was his
boyfriend was holding everything
together and it's unlike the weekend in
Taylor Swift I only do well when I'm
depressed and no business does well but
once I'm happy it's like [ __ ] man you're
sad again yeah create your best work
when you're sad yeah exactly how dare
you ruin the show someone killed my cat
or something oh my God
into existence
I kidnap him and then and then the show
will be regain again there you go yeah
because now Gina's surprise
so the funny thing is like we actually
filmed a goodbye episode
in Austin Casey play clip play clip yeah
I know this is our last episode we've
been saying it's our last episode on all
the episodes that we filmed here in
Austin but that's because we were just
making light of how this is actually our
last episode yeah we filmed it in a
corner of a hotel room with poor
lighting yeah um and we had to upturn a
bed to make space for the camera yeah
yeah
um but we decided to scrap that that
because we're like we're supposed to end
it like
yeah that was in May no it was July oh
yeah you're right yeah it's July that
was in July I know time's hard we kind
of know
that was a decade ago listen don't
listen to me when it comes to time she
talked about that in the last episode
yeah
um and then like yes so we decided to
scrap that and it's like you know what
it's better if we just if we do it here
in our home base yeah it's kind of
rushed too also we wanted to just finish
out the year like it felt weird to just
end in a random like July or something
you know so like we just finished out
the year and then yeah so Merry
Christmas
holiday shopping done we were filming
this before doing this in September yeah
this is it's like well because we're
trying to finish finish the whole rest
of the year I don't we're not uploading
the very last week of 2022 so it's not
like December 27th or yeah I talk
Logistics with them that's boring
um
my parents are getting divorced [ __ ] you
kids yeah wow I'm kidding Merry
Christmas the show's over yeah
you no longer have to hear from us
Jingle Bells [ __ ] but we had to
make
it a good episode so y'all don't think
some [ __ ] went down because some [ __ ]
probably went down in the past but
nothing went nothing went down nothing
went down now like we yeah this podcast
grew hell and back and you guys don't
even know yeah we can't even say because
there's you know there's reasons why but
but not with us not with us no not
between us and that's why we're like you
know if there was a way to end this show
let's end it on a good positive note
yeah we all get to be together back in
LA and kind of leave the door open you
know when we all started we were in the
same place kind of in life and work and
everything and it just made sense and
then now three years later I can't
believe it's over it's been over three
years over three years three and a half
years later we're all in completely
different lives like really and in a
beautiful way like everything that we
had hoped to like kind of happen each
one happened like the seeds were planted
and now they're growing into flowers and
beautiful trees and it's is Flowing I
think it's so sweet because our viewers
know that too yeah I've seen comments
like dude all their lives have gone in
such different directions now that it
would make sense if they like I think
I've seen some comments that were like
if they ended the podcast it does make
sense yeah you get a happy ending yeah
yeah and and it's not the end forever
obviously we'll still stay friends and
if like in a year or two we're like hey
you know what I miss you guys like we're
all in the same city again I don't know
it's not like hey this is a heart out
like we're ending it forever you know
what [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah
yeah you're cool
Isaac love you the rest of these [ __ ]
now peace see you in hell yeah yeah it's
like um it's it's it's it's like a I I
think it would be really fun if like
just randomly we just dropped a video
like like randomly here next year
something [ __ ] were bad so if
they could have a video that you're
tuning in to welcome New York yeah
three years of content to go through
exactly if you're interested and you
know what I really enjoy it like when I
look back I I love how our podcast
evolved like we at no point ever knew
what we were doing no we got to try a
lot of things like we went to airbnbs we
did like murder mystery murder mystery
mood um we did Vlogs we went on
adventures together we like moved to
different sets yeah so many sets and we
got to build each one together three
different sets right yeah photo shoots
and what was your favorite memory like
looking back on all of it uh I think
honestly my favorite memory was Big Bear
when we were all on the lake together oh
yeah yeah
there was like a emotional emotional
Moment Like a couple of that's the trip
where we heard them [ __ ] though
that's true that's why that's what I'm
saying
recording I was drunk
stairs thinking the whole house is gonna
come down yeah the A-frame was not
holding it together I told you guys my
bed moves to the center of my room
it really did like they shifted the
house on its pillars I legit thought
that there was an earthquake and the
whole place is coming down
yeah so I was like I I just heard Nikki
and Steve orgasm
no that was a crazy time like that was
my favorite memory yeah right that was a
crazy time because I remember
specifically that night
um I couldn't sleep and that's why I was
up hearing these [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
because they woke everyone up yeah I
couldn't sleep either yeah
I couldn't sleep because okay so this
trip for Big Bear was a very crazy
emotional trip for a couple of us it was
for Jess and it was for me uh and one of
the reasons for I mean for me I couldn't
sleep that night because my antibiotics
gave me an allergic reaction on my legs
that I broke out in hives and I was
itching because I was going through that
whole crazy situation yeah yeah yeah
SPD
antibiotics from a douchebag from RE
Choi on Tick Tock that was knowingly
spreading STDs so I was on like my seven
day antibiotics for that and um I I had
hives and I was itchy cured now by the
way
um and I that's why I was awake and then
I I remember just being awake I was like
oh
yeah I'm in a room by myself in a bunk
bed by the way
yeah
it's a kid's room yeah
it didn't work then I hear my parents
[ __ ] in the Next Room yeah
we told Nickelodeon
[Laughter]
a G4 yeah yeah contract God I was going
through like all this crazy [ __ ] with
thoughts and downs it like a huge
breakthrough happened in the whole like
drama on Tick Tock and then
um on the same weekend I was sitting on
the couch in the living room we were all
chilling and then I I shot up in from my
from the couch and I was like oh my God
I got G4
and I was like losing my mind I was so
happy and I was like how much money they
paid yeah how much money and I was like
it was it was like the craziest
experience of like the lowest lows and
the highest yeah and I was like but girl
you're rich now
I remember we just got that drinkworks
machine yeah
that was the trip where I first saw you
guys ever fight your first time yeah and
you know how dumb it was because I'm
like we never fight but like when we do
fight it's the dumbest
like that
because it's always like so it's
something [ __ ] stupid but then
there's this underlying thing that we're
like okay what was the underlying thing
we try to like solve it together in the
morning but like Steve was also
inebriated he was trash it's really hard
to like have a real conversation when
he's trashed but yeah the fight was over
whether or not he was a real Prince fan
sorry Casey
um yeah he kept thinking that I was
accusing him of being a fake fan but I
wasn't and then I was getting frustrated
that he he kept being like Oh I guess I
just I just watched Batman for no reason
and like became a fan when I was a kid
from and I guess me and my my dad bonded
over him for no reason I'm like I'm not
saying you're a fake fan like what the
[ __ ] and this was during while we were
playing cards with Cheetos so I'm like
yeah
[Applause]
that's still part of your stack I can
win that
but I remember like that argument we
didn't know what to do because we've
never seen them over the years we've
known you guys yeah you get to hear me
[ __ ] Anarchy yeah the same night on the
same trip yeah passionate people yeah
like all right Pierce divorcing oh no
never mind they're not they're [ __ ]
because you know how many nights we've
had where everyone's [ __ ] trashed and
like [ __ ] could have gone left never
fight never never fight yeah until one
night uh Steve thinks that his wife has
the audacity to say that he's not a
princess
humiliating him on purpose
and then that's what I had a bonding
moment with Nikki that night too yeah
yeah she came in because I was like
she went to her room and then she comes
down and she she's cuddling me and these
[ __ ] turn on Eminem and I was
like all night
out of the room yeah well I thought they
were like being malicious I thought
Steve was because Steve's a petty
[ __ ] yeah and so especially when
he's drunk he thinks it's so [ __ ]
funny so all night we were like
requesting songs so we were playing and
she had it and she was like we're not
playing Eminem I was like please just
play it I was like no [ __ ] she
wouldn't do it and then like he got to
request prints and that's what the whole
conversation started and so then I'm
like crying to Gina and Gina's like it's
okay like I'm spooning this [ __ ]
and then like my eyes are all right yeah
we were trying to get you to come
upstairs like maybe if we play Eminem
now she'll come back
we have different processes here they
try to lure her out like a [ __ ] yeah
and I was like well first of all we like
denied you all night yeah your husband's
[ __ ] yelling at you over some stupid
ass [ __ ] so with him let's draw her back
out with Eminem with anything so petty
like that's what the first thing I go do
is like he's like this will [ __ ] with
her yeah it wasn't his decision I
actually looking back in retrospect that
probably wasn't the best thing to play
yeah now that I'm down here crying yeah
I enjoy it she's not gonna be happy yeah
like well I mean our process
she likes Eminem yeah
guys I found a chat
it's like Mom she has rabies now
that night was the second I was after
the [ __ ] night it was it wasn't like
makeup sex no yeah so yeah it's like I'm
like you know what I understand my
little artists
and then the next day we went to the
lake and it was emotional on another
flight with yeah it was like near the
anniversary of my mom's death and I like
remember the first anniversary yeah it
was the first was it 20th 2021 no
because she died in 2019.
and that's why I think I was so
frustrated because I was like why am I
still so angry when I felt nothing but a
sense of relief like 2019 like when it
happened like obviously I was super sad
it kind of rocked me but I was like so
relieved because she was finally like
released from her torture of a life and
then that's kind of what opened me up to
like oh I need to like live my life and
like that's why my relationship finally
I was okay with letting it go because I
think I was done running from her too
yeah and so like all this [ __ ] was all
coming up man I'm like it's been two
years like why am I still so mad and
then Gina was there and I just like
started crying and she's gone
everyone
I'm like hugging yeah
I'm just like hold on
I'm so sorry but don't get too close
yeah yeah
it was like an indie movie where we all
threw away
like The Shins were playing in the
background somewhere we were skipping
rocks it was so cute that's true yeah
and I was bummed I missed out on the
heartwarming moment because they all did
a group hug and but I was off to the
side with Casey like we're vlogging or
something I don't even think oh yeah we
did really set but anyway yeah and I was
like I turned back and I'm like she's
like
yeah it was all I knew how to do like
I'm not good with words yeah so I saw
Jess I'm like I was like I don't even
have anything to say I'm just angry yeah
for no reason you know you were probably
dealing with each stage of grief yeah
each year because you kind of pushed it
down when it wasn't the anniversary so
it's like you're not dealing with those
emotions and then it comes back up it's
like oh you haven't processed this part
yeah it's like hello remember uh yeah
probably still more down in here you
know I remember like um in that moment
when I saw you I was like I need to hug
her because I don't know what to say and
I also didn't want to force you to talk
about it yeah I figured some people just
don't want to talk about it they just
want to hug but I remember thinking like
she's not very affectionate you know so
I'm like
all right we're just gonna we're gonna
go for it
wait was the Big Bear trip the one that
had a jacuzzi and me and you went in
yeah yeah I never wanted that Jacuzzi I
mean also it happened that week it was
really good it was Peak uh me having
whatever the covet thing is where you're
where everything is
the Indian restaurant just smelled like
chemical everything smelled like a
condom like a [ __ ] brand new condom
like the rubber like you can taste the
chemical latex no one else had that
issue oh this is great
um you guys brought home like uh avocado
toast that had like onion on it one day
and I could smell it across the room it
was just I remember first hearing about
the um
robot bartender yeah and I was like oh
[ __ ] that sounds so cool I'm thinking
like this is a [ __ ] automatic dude
with a model
Top Hat it's just a cute [ __ ] Keurig
I'm usually calling it a robot so we can
boss him around but I think you guys are
the ones who uh because of that machine
uh I tried a a Moscow Mule for the first
time yeah really yeah and I was like
this is Joe those are pre-made gross
ones too like they were pretty good yeah
they're pretty good because I need a
real one a fresh one is better right but
I didn't start drinking mildly until uh
coven and this was like midnight yeah
you'd start drinking till kovitz
didn't you like throw up on my birthday
yeah the fact that you weren't drinking
the whole time that's true oh yeah and
on my birthday at the karaoke
you ordered a bottle oh yeah
I guess Gina every time I've seen you
you were drinking but it was like
special it was like yeah
so I'm like Gina we don't just like hang
out every weekend it's like how people
on YouTube used to think I drink all the
time because every time I made videos
I'd like be drinking while I was cooking
but you're like this is for the video
like I literally get drunk off half a
drink yeah I don't really let's go down
the line what was your favorite moment
um wow there's a lot I'm there's a we've
been through a lot dude no
um
in public yeah yeah also another thing
about that Big Bear trip we were playing
poker I had never played in a casino in
a like public card room yet that was
like the beginning I didn't even have my
own it was like the very very beginning
it was like of the obsession anyway
um San Diego all almost all my memories
were like the trips
one where we did Christmas yes
Thanksgiving cookies like Thanksgiving
and we did like Thanksgiving and
Christmas stuff yeah and we did we did
put that on the channel yeah we made
cookies we did film Vlogs like that and
Big Bear what was the first one more
like I don't think we should release any
of these videos yeah yeah that was like
the end of it I think we had two videos
that never came out San Diego was no it
was no it was Big Bear when you said you
know why doesn't your oh inside match
your outside no no no
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that was one of
the funniest things I've ever heard you
say did you do you just belched or
something or yeah
it's so pretty on the outside
and I think the uh the tree house one
where we made Christmas cookies and
that's when you had me try tofurkey for
the first time oh yeah and I was pissed
because it was delicious she's like
don't eat too much of it though because
it might give you diarrhea all the
reviews say that but it was actually
really good yeah you got a text and eat
tofurkey so you yeah or something that
day that was when you told me I think
that's the first time I heard you say
the best thing about Steve cooking for
himself is watching them have to eat and
I lost my mind laughing it was so good
my favorite
yeah I might I don't know it's her
favorite moment yeah I like to put
little pieces of each one into like me
too box same because uh I'm like
thinking about all I like I really liked
the tree house one and we all like did a
moon ritual too yeah like those cute I
really do like meditation we did a moon
meditation yeah yeah I think the best
part about all those trips is everyone
was just open to whatever yeah I was
reading tarot cards yeah
that's right they had weird books did we
release that video I don't remember yeah
wait yeah we did I'm like I can't
remember because I feel like uh someone
was reading my tarot and I was like is
it this guy and the cards were like no
no like it was like I just I remember
that when we I was reading tarot cards
for you guys off camera it was really
yeah
it was so the magic when it got scared I
remember doing sit-ups and you guys
spring whipped cream in my mouth Tick
Tock that was for a tick tock that you
wanted like it's a reward it's like a
reward remember I was doing like booty
bouncing stuff
going like this yeah I was like no
you're going the wrong direction that
trip that um
that house which house was it the uh the
house where we did the photo shoot that
was a scary scary house
that was your yeah she was your that was
a Culver City right you guys made it
scary yeah skincare yeah right then Jess
and I room together because we did some
reason it was creepy we made it creepy
yeah there was like there was everything
in the wall there was a hole that and
they're like what if the blood I don't
remember what you guys said
noxious gas yeah it was a weird [ __ ] in
the shower what the shower was weird
like the the way that they built it was
like there was like it was like enclosed
like an enclosed place to shout I can't
describe it it was just actually you
guys can see it it's on our Channel and
that's when we had our cooking contests
yes the breakfast thing cook-off yeah
because you salted like a lot on hers
and not on mine yeah
uneven salting yes people always say
it's about the journey not the
destination and they're right getting
there effortlessly is what Bays luggage
and bags were made for phase is there
for your journey wherever your next
destination might be I freaking love my
base bags I have so many of them that
I've collected over the years it has
been life-changing because every single
bag is built to Max Effectiveness so I
have pockets for everything pockets for
my makeup pockets for my hard drive
pockets for my laptop my computer my
passport I have a water bottle bag that
they created that is just basically a
crossover body bag just to carry my
water bottle and my phone and keys and
that is so perfect for the gym or long
poker tournament sessions um I also have
this uh travel crossover body bag that
is built to like hold your passport and
your money and your cash and all that
stuff and there's just so many so many
so many convenient uses for all of their
different types of bags I absolutely
love their carry-on the a rolly bag
carry-on it has a compressor to make
sure you get maximum effectiveness of
how much you can pack in your bag as
well as the Weekender bag which holds up
to three pairs of shoes in the bottom so
I don't even have to worry about that
taking space in my actual luggage it's
just great everything about it is great
there's also a trolley on the Weekender
bag so I can put it on my roller
carry-on bag which means I don't have to
hurt my shoulders carrying it around the
airport all day it's awesome phase was
created by actress Shea Mitchell to make
sleek and affordable bags luggage and
accessories designed to help you travel
effortlessly while still looking
fashionable and I think she achieved
that goal right now base has offered our
listeners 15 off your first purchase by
visiting phasetravel.com big mood go to
basetravel.com big mood for 15 off your
first purchase that's b-e-i-s
travel.com slash big mood when I
remember that night with Jess like it
was so creepy and weird
and then like we went to bed and then I
was like I'm gonna wait for this [ __ ]
to fall asleep she's like sitting there
sitting on her phone you guys were
roommates a lot because at my house
right at the tree house yeah yeah
because yeah that was scary for me
because she had a [ __ ] like ghost
sounds going on it was a sound machine
of waves and I was like this place
each wave it literally I was like oh
dude I was like Nikki would love this
she's a beach baby she loves the ocean
she would love to like Yeah by the ocean
yeah yeah
no [ __ ] clue you did know you forgot
I forgot I vaguely remembered it like
way later the memory snapped in when we
went to sleep and you're like by the way
I'm gonna put on a noise machine okay
I wake up like holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] she got so scared it's coming
from somewhere have we always been
roommates except for the Hawaii I mean
the Mexico trip me and you were oh yeah
yeah I wasn't there you weren't there
I'd make every other we've been
roommates every other time
telling me those ranch when you weren't
there yeah yeah we were roommates
because Tiff was pregnant and we gave
her the queen sweet yeah
we didn't film did we film call me
ghosts I vlogged it on my channel but I
didn't I don't think we filmed it we
were mermaids all of them I liked it a
lot yeah I sought comfort in hearing
Jess giggle to herself with her airpods
airpods on and then breathing while
she's sleeping like okay she's good
oh yeah she does do that like she'll
watch videos before bed yeah
I was so like I felt lonely in my room
so I cuddled in the middle of them
yeah I only came to bed after I was done
with playing poker on me yeah I know we
were like
it's a free World Poker Tournaments your
poker oh we had a fireplace on too yeah
yeah
oh yeah that was when I was yeah I had
just put an offer on the house and they
accepted it and so um I had to send that
I had to sign document saying that I was
going to send them
um like a earnest money which was like a
kind of like a deposit in the morning
um and I was like oh my God it's like
happening like and I was like so nervous
trying to read oh and the the person
that made the document was Caldwell
really oh remember I was like do your
brothers
not in Nevada yeah we also don't have
the same ones it was kind of a sign too
actually chess was the one that talked
me into getting the house because you're
gonna buy some stupid shitty motorcycle
theme house and I was like get the nicer
you're the nice one but it no I I think
it was self-sabotaging honestly because
I had talked to myself well I loved this
house and then I got there and I was
like it's not that great like my
contractor friend was like well the
floors are kind of cheap or whatever and
he was kind of saying that from the
Realtors to get the price down but I was
like you didn't really catch on yeah and
I was like oh yeah it was kind of cheap
WOW and it was like beautiful right yeah
and then gorgeous house and then I was
like well it's out of our price range
and so then he got it down like to our
price range and I was like well the
house next door wouldn't for cheaper and
and like but I don't really want to move
I don't want to live in that one yeah
and um and then they got it down even
further where it was like definitely
like way in our price range what's wrong
with it and he's like checked I he's a
contractor like for 30 years and he
checked everything he's like
everything's great like it's just like a
few superficial things like maybe
replacing some light bulbs or whatever
and I'm like you just want to get rid of
the house yeah I was like well I read
the numerology on the address it was
gonna be boring I was like Nikki please
I'm just like what's wrong with you why
are you doing this to yourself I don't
know
I love it now gosh I feel like yeah like
I I put a lot of them together into one
so like I feel like there's just little
moments that we had at each one like I I
can't pick like a favorite one yeah you
know it's hard because like there's like
not the whole weekend was amazing at any
one trip but like there was parts of it
like remember when we were at the San
Diego house and we were all getting
blasted and like me and Steve were like
white people dancing yeah and then like
it was just
sliding glass door and like she was like
shut the [ __ ] up Bishop if you were in
Texas you would have gotten shot yeah
that's why they live in California but
she didn't know she had a valid points I
didn't know we're like the music doesn't
go up that loud I mean because he wasn't
trying to turn it up and we turned it to
maximum and it was like barely okay it
was the outdoor speakers yeah so the
whole neighborhood was getting blasted
or the music Porsche the where the pool
was
neighborhood is like really small too
like everyone's like okay
but still don't walk into the house
she's probably like shouting forever
it's so funny yeah that house we didn't
publicize at all yeah we didn't well we
didn't
um film any videos there yeah it was
kind of like I don't think we even did
stories either like we just we just were
like it was just one of ourselves that
we're like we don't want to do we want
to think about it I don't think we
filmed anything that's what I'm saying
this is for us like for me personally my
favorite is everything that was off
camera like all our actual friendship
moments that
was the most special for me but it
fueled like the content like that we
talked about like where like we have
like it's all like life-building
memories and I also think another reason
why we can't pick a favorite moment is
because we were in like different stages
of our Evolution at each so much change
yeah I feel like that's kind of fun to
go around and talk about like how we
were so different yeah at the beginning
of this podcast to where we're at now
yeah true yeah like I guess I'll go
first yeah I like the beginning I'm just
gonna say right now one of my most
favorite moments in this whole entire
podcast
was when I got to meet your stupid
[ __ ] baby for the first time oh you
[ __ ] kiss ass she's such a little
piece of [ __ ] anyways continue yeah
because anyways just because you have a
very special honorable place of being
the very first person outside of family
to hold him yeah it was dope I had to
make a good impression
whatever no but yeah like for me like
the person I was when this podcast
started back in 2019
I like completely different I don't even
remember that was really 2019 too that
was like when we were in Vegas like
March of 2019 when we were first talking
about it that's true not pregnant like
Jess and Joseph yeah my mom was still
alive like non-blond Jess yeah like
brown yeah she had just dyed her hair
before the show yeah
whoa yeah and like just my whole being
of a person like to the point I was so
different to the point where in the
middle of all this they're like Steve
coined the term tiffasants I was going
to yeah because I was actually like
finding my voice finding my confidence
finding myself standing up for yourself
standing up for myself and like no
longer being like used and abused in
different ways and I don't know just
I'm really proud of
the Tifa Sans era like yeah it's just I
needed that I put it into into deep Tiff
yeah yeah I remember I stand up for
myself too yeah I remember the moment
that I noticed so I realized that was
when I was having trouble deciding
something in the group and you were like
Gina do you understand like blah blah
blah and I was like what do you mean
you know you talked to me I was like oh
[ __ ] and it's like if Tiff's telling you
what the [ __ ] yeah that's how you know
yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] and for Tiff
to do that I was like okay this is this
is really serious this is real like all
right yeah yeah shit's changing yeah
it's going down yeah yeah and then like
during that time too like you know with
Casey and I trying to like work out work
on our marriage and like get to a better
place where we can get pregnant because
we had been wanting we hadn't even
gotten your house yet no we didn't have
a house yeah we were still renting yeah
that's wild yeah and now look at us we
have our home we have our baby it's like
crazy like I went to therapy all worked
on yourself we're a lot better yeah that
yeah like the fact that we're like
thinking of another baby like it's just
crazy it's crazy it's like another baby
we want Luca to have us have like a
sibling close to him yeah cause um
like I didn't get to grow up with
siblings Isaac didn't get to grow up
with siblings so I feel really guilty
that I did that to Isaacs I really
didn't want to I didn't want him to be
an only child and you want to have your
home birth experience yeah I want to get
that like that what's the term I can't
think of the term but like I want to be
able to close my birthing experiences
with the thing that I've been wanting
the most like that I deserve it that I'm
entitled to I want to be like my good
birth not like in the San Diego I have
to see this [ __ ] but like maybe upstairs
in the vents
take care of Luca we're chewing cashews
in your ear yeah
just call me when that whole thing's
over I'll be there yeah yeah or like
whenever you guys want your babies yeah
yeah yeah
I will birth them I might need to yeah I
will getting up there yeah well do you
really though for real maybe I was
telling them yesterday I was like for
sure you guys I would but Nikki maybe
not because I don't know if you for sure
would what want to oh I feel like you
would want to go through the whole you
think that process yes
like you would actually have oh I'm
seeing for health reasons so my
neighbors just had to use a surrogate
after trying IVF for four years because
like her body like it would take but
then she would miscarriage or like you
know still birth because it was just
yeah and like her eggs were so good his
sperm was still good she just couldn't
carry it and so and like she's not that
much older than me and so I'm like whoa
like I don't to save myself like the
Heartbreak of that maybe just pick a
healthier
younger person to carry but I don't know
like yeah I do I would want like if I
was to get pregnant I would want yeah
the whole like experience right yeah
yeah not me yeah me neither yeah that's
what I'm like for sure you guys yeah are
on the way your husband's not gonna like
it though he's already like no I don't
think so yeah but it's my body whatever
he doesn't matter
he doesn't matter
but she really does like have an
orgasmic experience giving birth like
the way she wants to and she's just like
addicted to like giving birth
like you can give me an army if you want
I just don't want to do it yeah like I
don't want to go through that part of it
can you keep it until it's like five two
because like can you raise a little bit
I would be down to birth your B to
incubate birth and keep your baby for
like the first four months
for you yeah new baby business 30 grand
no I'm already gonna be 33 at the end of
this year no wait she's like I only got
a few years left I think if he was being
23. I don't know why you're 29. yeah 28
27 I'm in my 20s forever yeah everyone
stays the age they were when I met them
yeah no but if it's not my egg and sperm
yeah and if my womb is still healthy
blooming I honestly why not there's
women that have kids in their 50s yeah
you're Latina like exactly yeah
I'll be safe you're good I think I'd be
good yeah just blink a sperm in your
direction yeah
I don't know we've tried for years it
was too precious you were unhappy yeah
yeah you were unhappy and yeah your body
my body was rejecting yeah that's why I
was I'm really proud of our marriage
that we got to the place where we got
pregnant yeah like we're good and like
Luca's here and he's happy yeah he's a
really happy baby yeah he is he's really
happy where does that come from
does that come from I'm telling you
because there was happiness finally
blossoming like whatever happens when
you get pregnant is like what the baby
is like yourself because they have my
mental health because like stress
literally the the day I found out I was
pregnant was a huge alleviation of
stress yeah like the biggest of my life
for the past decade so it was just been
Blissful yeah yeah it's awesome yeah I
feel like Jesse went through a Jesse
Sons too yeah you totally oh my God you
totally did like holy [ __ ] Jess that
started his podcast to this job yeah
[ __ ] wild yeah
like I didn't think that I had much to
offer I guess in the terms of like why
am I even on the show or like I should
maybe I shouldn't even be yeah you both
were dubbed The Quiet Ones yeah like
kind of useless not not yes
I would never it was told to my face
yeah but not not people in this room no
no no yes yes yes
so anyway
s and they're drinking wine
um
I um yeah like I don't know I I
definitely think that like just having
you guys not even the show but just like
having you guys be there for me after my
breakup like was definitely the crutch
that I needed and like also just the
support that I got from everyone and
like and we gave that to each other yeah
genuinely support yeah growth in life
like I felt free like all the stages
like that the messy stages even it's
like I had stability in you guys
you guys gave me like the security that
I needed like the emotional security
that I needed and it helped me get
through honestly I could say the same
too like for me personally with what I
was going through that's definitely yeah
you guys gave me the strength I think I
was very insecure before I had you guys
like really close to me and now I just
feel like I could do anything and I kind
of have like yeah I've like passed a CPA
exam I work in like the second largest
CPA firm in the world like I like I was
able to be like okay stop focusing on
[ __ ] like you can do this you can do
anything yeah I'm smart yeah I got my
whole life ahead of me people do like me
you know yeah exactly yeah I remember
early on I we weren't close at all yeah
we didn't really know each other and
we're so different we're so different
yeah and I remember like
bluntly
I can take it when when Jess would say
like
definitive things about things yeah I'm
like no you're wrong dude you're [ __ ]
dumb
you're new in this group I don't know I
don't know fine whatever and then it
turned out to be true and I was like oh
[ __ ] all right yeah that's a fluke
whatever it comes in your kitchen and
goes these knives are bad
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh they are kind of okay
because they're so dull it's like I just
didn't understand Jess I'm like you're
this new person you don't get you know
yeah and then I was like you don't
really know what you're talking about
yeah and then later on like oh she was
right yeah she's never been wrong yeah
and then the second time around like
oh [ __ ] is she right again oh [ __ ] she's
right and then but the relationship with
me and you was like I barely know this
[ __ ] too um
oh she knows and she doesn't sugarcoat
it and she's right and like that's when
I knew I was like I can trust every guy
that you brought in front of me I was
like hmm yeah yeah
I I didn't I didn't I had a hard time
accepting it in the beginning not just
dating but like relationships
friendships yeah family whatever in
general where I'm like what the [ __ ]
does she know and every time she turned
out to be right I was like this [ __ ] is
smart I'm paying attention yeah I'm
actually paying attention and observing
and I'm like hmm yeah feeling like
different
psychological types yeah where like
other people are like oh no you know
they whatever they're sugar coating it
Jess is like no dude this is no yeah
it's like and then it took me
at first I didn't really but after a
while I'm like okay she actually knows
what she's doing this is why she's doing
it it's out of good faith and you know
and she's not sugar coating it because
she loves you exactly and I appreciate
your opinion on everything so much more
yeah yeah I'm glad that we were able to
get close because I I just never thought
like when I first came around years ago
like [ __ ] eight years ago or
something like I never thought that I
would be like Gina's just we're just so
different we're never gonna be close but
then now like you just like me right
away stupid
I like heard for the Grapevine it was
like my girlfriend likes you I'm like
yeah me
that's
Joe's girlfriend that's all it was you
know yeah and now it's like I went
through some of like probably my worst
[ __ ] depression ever yeah the first
person I called was Jess yeah and she
was the first one to like
I [ __ ] love that talk me out of it
you know like just [ __ ] incredible I
love you yeah love me too
um yeah I mean that's how I felt about
your guys's breakup too like
[ __ ] the people that are like no that's
just how relationship story I'm gonna
drink it's like you're not you don't
care about your friend's happiness
actually like if you can't put the
pieces together that like maybe both of
these people will be happier in other
relationships or just on their own and
really yeah then like you're not a good
friend like I'm sorry like a good friend
is gonna tell you you know bluntly but
gently like this is not incredible like
I care about you and this is what I see
and you make your own choices I won't
have judgment for you I'll support you
whatever but
um but this is do you really want this
like you know and I think that's what
she did for you it's like do you really
like really yeah just think the only
person not like you guys did anything
wrong yeah like just or Steve really
advocated for my previous relationship
because he met the dude like a couple
times Steve is uh he didn't have all the
information he didn't have all the
information yeah yeah because the female
intuition yeah I definitely there was
peop he just trust sees the good in
people right away which is great and and
he has a gift of being able to see the
good and uplift that part in people and
like really like let people know realize
their inner yeah strength and their
their strengths you know and emphasizes
that but sometimes to his detriment
where I'm like this person's taking
advantage of you and and he doesn't see
it he's like no yeah like you don't
understand like I'm like no and I think
that's the sweetest thing that he wants
to see the good in people yeah so bad
and that's why we love him so much but
Jess from day one yeah I remember we had
a whole fight around the the kitchen or
the dining table at Nikki's house like I
was almost fighting with Steve because I
was like no no and he's like yeah but
just give it a time you know I'm like no
yeah just from day one then I went
silent I was like y'all are all [ __ ]
wrong
and I didn't listen to Jess because I
wanted so bad to believe that yeah I've
been there I've done the same yeah and
but like yes from day one just we'll let
you know like this is not good for you
Gina I'm not gonna [ __ ] sugarcoat it
and make you feel better this is not
good for you and she was right yeah and
I just didn't want to believe it so now
Jess is like my [ __ ] Compass
it's like just should I where's your
North yeah
these eggs are about to expire but it's
a great price should I buy it or not
it's just everything she's like they
have to put the expiration date way
before it actually expires
she's my magic eight ball now like I
trust Justin just like anything she says
is a Bible to me
that's how this group is like balance
each other whenever one is two in their
own thing they like don't have good
judgment because they're just too sucked
in another is like hey this is actually
what's going on yeah can you see it
yeah yeah yeah I think that's why this
podcast always has worked really well
too between us like we each bring a
different perspective to the table and
there's our audience like you know you
guys relate to each of us in different
ways and I don't know that's how we were
able to maintain this for three years
yeah but it just I don't know three and
a half I think it's three and a half
it's very interesting because
just has always been kind of like a
firecracker and like not in like a bad
way but like the odd man out where like
we did so many episodes of am I the
[ __ ] but there were so many comments
were like I want to hear Jess on this
yeah yeah you know and it's like
everyone knows like
you may be like the other the other like
the the person fighting for the other
side double that and it's like it's like
[ __ ] God damn it she makes sense all
right you know like it's like so it's
like I don't want to agree with you but
you might be right and that's why like
people wanted to see you so bad yeah
yeah and then Nikki hmm look at you
living your my retired life yeah I I'm
taking your beautiful apartment
do any of you guys feel that Eco guilt
because I know I sure do especially when
it comes to my food waste for the
longest time in my household we always
separate our food waste but I never
composted because it's really
complicated to try to do your own
composting like I just I never
understood how to do it so instead of
actually doing something with those food
scraps we would just throw it in the
trash in the regular old bin and I
honestly did feel kind of guilty where
I'm like man you know what this food
waste could totally be used to turn it
into some nutrient rich soil but I ain't
got time for that so I just never did I
would just throw it in the waist and I
would think about how it's just piling
up in the landfill when it could serve a
purpose enter loamy loamy allows me to
turn my food scraps into dirt with a
push of a button blow me is a countertop
electric composter that turns scraps to
dirt in under four hours there is
absolutely no smell when it runs and
it's super quiet thanks salomi I have
way less garbage each week I used to go
from so many bags I honestly can't even
tell you maybe about like three bags per
day of food scraps and now we literally
don't ever throw out any food scraps at
all we just throw it all into the low
meat and it just turns into dirt and I
reuse that dirt for my pots as soil or
I'll just throw it in the green bin
which I know is going to be used for the
environment we honestly use Arlo meat
every single day after every single meal
all of our food scraps go in there and I
just love the fact that now our house
doesn't smell like nasty food waste I
probably run the loamy about maybe like
once every two-ish days and whenever I
do run it it's only because it's gotten
filled up but it's never because it
actually smells like my loamy never
stinks up my kitchen and once it
actually does run and it turns into dirt
that dirt actually smells pretty great
where I'm like how is it possible at
this nasty food actually turned into
this pretty good smelling dirt it's
really interesting but I honestly feel
great knowing that I'm composting now
and I'm creating soil instead of waste I
have basically a limitless supply of
dirt for my garden so it's such a
win-win no more stinkiness no more trash
going into the landfill and now my
potted plants get nutrient-rich soil if
you want to start making a positive
environmental impact or just make clean
up after dinner that much easier loamy
is perfect for you head to loamy.com Big
mood and use the promo code big mood to
get 50 off your loamy that's 50 off when
you head to
lomi.com Big mood and use code big mood
at checkout food waste is gross Lomi is
your solution with the holidays just
around the corner Lomi will make the
perfect gift for someone on your
shopping list because side note I
honestly bought someone alone me already
because they were just I was raving
about it and they were like oh my God
it's amazing and then I was like oh my
God perfect I didn't know what to get to
for Christmas so I actually purchased a
loamy for them anyway highly recommend
it check them out yeah I've thrown a
ride you know I feel like there was a
lot I mentally the person that I've
always been of like I've always been
this like
high anxiety like hustle get things done
be productive because it I it was the
came from a place of
um like being really poor like being
really broke and then like figuring out
how to make the life that uh like the
work life that I like sustained my
livelihood and like and then
like be I ran out of fear of like losing
that so it was always just like I would
not let myself freaking rest because I
just didn't want to lose things that I
built and I just wanted to like keep
things together and like keep the chip
from sinking and like all the [ __ ] and
then like moving to Vegas or at least it
probably happened before then mentally
but like when we actually moved like
this past year has been like a what if I
didn't like what if I didn't hustle that
hard what if I just for the first time
ever in my life and this probably came
from my dad just being like you know you
have to like be disciplined and I have
really good discipline but I've never
not been disciplined and I never knew
what that felt like to just like relax
like that word's a foreign word and even
now like when I'm like okay relax I'm
like
I have to do laundry and then I have to
be better and there's a whole thing that
I'm like no just relax and I'm like okay
oh wow this guy's really blue and like I
don't know what time it is right now
whoa that's weird I usually always know
what time it is like oh these things are
kind of do but like do they have to be
due what's consequence if they're not if
I don't turn it in like what happens and
like oh nothing really so okay well
let's just don't do it I'm like are we
really not gonna turn it in oh my God
yeah you've had a teacher behind your
back like your whole life or something
and like I finally ditched classes
I'm supposed to be in class yeah I'm
drinking a Slurpee yeah yeah
um yeah and it's been like plenty of
like quiet in your brain you feel like
yeah and like um yeah I think that's why
because I I definitely like lost weight
too which I was unexpected I've not been
trying you know there's many years where
I was trying to lose weight I had sibo
and all this crazy [ __ ] happening with
me but
um I the first thing my nutritionist
said was like what do you do for work
and then tried to eliminate things so
that I could get stress off my plate
because she said that stress was
blocking my digestive system from
working and I think it was the first
time in my life where like I'm not that
stressed like I'm stressed that I'm like
maybe I should be more stressed like I'm
like is there something weird
relax yeah like like what happens like
what if I'm letting my whole life slip
now yeah
um and I you know start getting worried
about that but like for the most part
I've been just having this Gap year of
like what oh my God like what brings me
joy every day let's do that about
rollerblades I'm rollerblading like I
just like go swimming when I want to
like oh it's hot out I'm gonna put on a
bathing suit and jump in the pool and
like that was fun okay I don't want to
go journal or I don't know like
I just kind of have just been feeding
that inner child you know and I think
that there was just a lot of
things she didn't get to do she was told
no to she was taught to be more
disciplined I was always the older child
so I was taking care of my brother a lot
and like always having to be like super
extra responsible and then you know
being self-employed like making sure
that that ship is running making sure
I'm in charge of all the finances the
taxes the like making sure the household
runs and
this year I just been like what if I
didn't worry about anything and it's
been like really
hard to do that but like kind of
life-changing in that regard like if I
met if five three years ago me met me
and now she'd be like what the [ __ ] like
yeah how but what happens if if you
money doesn't come like what happens
like how how are you not caring about
that and also like your career stuff too
like you were still trying to act and
stuff yeah like I was worried about
auditions and like wanting to make sure
it really came down to people placing
honestly like I wanted to I wanted my
manager not to be disappointed that he's
sending me out on all these auditions
and I'm not booking anything and like I
wanted to like make sure that the people
that watch my videos were having a good
time and like I really didn't like look
at like am I having a good time you know
am I happy with what I'm doing am I
proud of anything that I've done yeah
and like it it was just kind of like a
huge perspective shift and it happened
through therapy too I was going through
a lot of [ __ ] in 2020 and my therapist
was just basically talking about how
I've probably been living my life for
other people and like fulfilling their
dreams like from childhood on like
um there's just I forget what she called
it but she broke down just like my
everyone has their different roles in
the family and like your role was kind
of like the glue and like kind of
fulfilling everyone else's needs and not
like asking yourself like what do I want
like what do I actually like this and
kind of just convincing myself that like
no this is for me but it's like no it's
not really right and so yeah this was
the first year where I was like what
like really ignites that spark in me
again and I didn't never expected it to
be poker to be honest like I like that
game I like it
um and Mafia is kind of similar and it's
really fun it's always been fun but I if
I was like
I want to be a poker player like I would
have never
super random it it makes sense it I've
always scored like the 50 50 on the
brain thing left right brain and like
that game like really utilizes both
halves in a way that like makes me feel
whole like even the tilting moments
where I'm like losing I'm like I don't
care like that was the right move to
make even though I lost that pod and
it's just very like it's analytical it's
emotional it's psychological it's like
all the things I've ever been passionate
about studying and being like your most
true authentic yourself with every
decision like finding yeah and that's
what this year has really been is just
like getting down to even even the
Shadow Self I know we had talks about
like the shadow stuff before and I
didn't really truly understand it it's
like the parts of you that you like
everyone's your whole self it's it's
Incorporated
[ __ ]
it's incorporating the parts that you're
embarrassed to even admit that are part
of you like where like you're darker no
one in society likes those parts like
people don't like but the part of you
that wants to try human meat that's kind
of a shadow thing not wrong
we should be accepted
that's adorable
yeah it's just like the parts that you
were trying to hide because you know
Society is like shamed you for it like
you know maybe you talk too much or
maybe you like
um get like really hyper sometimes or
like you uh you sometimes want attention
even though like you don't always want
to touch but sometimes you like kind of
want attention or like you and so you
instead turn on that side of yourself
and you're like oh people that want
attention or people that talk too much
or this or people that then you like
start judging other people for that part
of you that you don't want to
acknowledge kind of exists there and
when you kind of become friends with it
and are like hey you know like go ahead
you know do that annoying thing that I
think is so cringe and like I'm
embarrassed of like what does that feel
like did you get it like and then you
kind of become friends and you're like
that part of you doesn't want to act up
as much anymore and it's like I don't
want the attention because yeah it's
like oh thanks for giving that to me
like I appreciate it I'm gonna go back
to sleep now and yeah I guess I just
never even wanted to acknowledge that
part exist it existed and
and it's been like a really like big
journey of like what it like I always
thought I was being my authentic self
but then like digging even deeper like
truly truly like what is she where is
she who is she like what is she what's
living down there that I've suppressed
or whatever and yeah it's been
enlightening and then now I'm just
having an existential crisis of like is
my purpose done I think I'm done like I
think I'm done
I competed I completed the boss level
and like I fought all the demons I think
I'm pretty much done like do you want me
to do anything else I don't know if
there's other things to do and Steve's
like how dare you don't leave me and I'm
like I don't know that's what happens
yeah so I'm gonna continue my struggle
and continue to work so that I don't
think about that being done like I have
to do more things because there's like
times you've got like 30 more years to
figure out what to tell people like
don't you wanna have kids still like I
don't know yeah if they come I'm not
gonna deny them all the other Naturals
steps yeah what are you gonna do go find
another job like yeah
become a Vegas showgirl tune in to my
Vlog Channel next chapter I don't know
yeah Gina you've come a long way
yeah look at you how do you feel in a
relationship that you've actually kind
of like I'm not happy in your game in
your job that you had like you were okay
but you were like there were parts now
you're on TV girl uh all right well it's
our last episode
what are you doing you itching your butt
okay oh she's releasing vaping
um
what are you feeding her more alcohol
so you know last episode and you know
I've been drinking also dude the last
three years I've been [ __ ] insane
like probably the worst things I've been
through in my life yeah
um
and the best I would say yeah it's like
yeah it's like this dichotomy it's very
strange and so like I quit smoking
fantastic like I quit smoking vaping 10
years ago
2014 maybe almost time maybe you started
again and then I started again because
it got bad within the last three years
like it was just like all that stresses
yeah
um I went through so many changes in
life
um so when I first started the podcast I
was just I was streaming waking up at
two in the afternoon going to bed at
like five in the morning you know just
like this genus is [ __ ] Gremlin that
never shows up on time ever and then I'm
like all right there's these girls that
I see all the time like cool whatever I
have like no really like attachment to
you like my closest friends were the
people I've known since since high
school yeah
and then I got thrown into this podcast
where it's like
it was a financial thing for me at first
like yeah this works it's it's business
you know yeah and then I was like uh
after a while I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm
starting to love these people
what an inconvenience stupid you know
and I realized that over the years that
you guys have become very important
pillars of my life Tiff you are my peace
no you give me hope for marriage and
having a baby and I think that moment
came when
randomly you and I were hanging out my
room we fell asleep and we napped
together in my bed it's like my favorite
friendship moment actually no uh Austin
topped that
awesome what happened in Austin about
your stupid [ __ ] baby no
um I didn't mean to interrupt but
because I'm like I want to keep hearing
more no um
[Laughter]
I will say that I'm so painfully
straight but the only time I've ever
read it was episode yes yes I knew it
I'm so painfully straighted
up I was like I did not know anything
the only time I've ever had a lesbian
dream was with tips she was in my dream
did you have to tell me oh yeah she
brought it up on an episode so this was
your channel okay no but I still haven't
heard it was weird but tell it I hate
her [ __ ] what
and I was like look I am so painfully
straight I
I experimented before when I was 18.
I'm thinking about it now too like yeah
I experimented once when I was 18 and
that's when I realized now I'm straight
as [ __ ]
but the only time I've ever had a
lesbian dream was Tiff and I woke up I
was like I was like not for free Gina
don't say it for free yeah whatever last
episode
you know usually like like if I'm gonna
have a one-time sex dream it's gonna be
like some like celebrity yeah like yeah
yeah that's very cute
it's such a compliment I'm really
honored I swear no so my favorite
friendship moment that topped the us
falling asleep is it so in Austin when
we were driving to the sushi spot after
we filmed we had no uh she was in the
car with me because she got [ __ ] lost
like she was in the elevator and we were
like
we had such a deep conversation you're
pretty in the car yeah in the car so
we're outside you don't even remember it
yeah no she was literally my favorite
moment yeah no we were literally we're
crying we were literally crying she was
holding my hand she was telling me how
proud she is yeah she loves my life and
how because she remembers when we first
met and like where my life was at at
that point and it was just the most
touching most like beautiful like most
heartfelt like expression of like how
she's I don't know how to describe it
yeah yeah like the most beautiful
expression of friendship I've ever heard
and I was just like do you know
literally in the car right now yeah that
was oh I remember that yeah wait it was
like Casey in the car yeah so we were in
his parents
um yeah where
in the apartment uh it was Isaac his dad
or Casey's dad oh yeah so yeah so Casey
said I was in the trunk
so it was a d class yeah we couldn't
have like more scenes anyway and then
Casey was driving where's Isaac no Isaac
wasn't there Isaac yeah
Luca was in the car seat and then me and
Jean on the back seat and then Casey's
mom in the front yeah that's how it was
so he was driving to uchiko yeah yes
yeah I was drunk as [ __ ] and I was
holding her hand I was telling her how
proud I was of her and where she's gone
through in life
um and I realized it was not gonna hurt
like telling you to I'm like look at you
girl how far you got yeah we were oh it
was I now realize that Tiff and I have
shared the most
um intimate moments that uh yeah every
time everybody you ate her [ __ ] yeah
ate a [ __ ] dresses [ __ ] yeah you're
pushing my dreams it was weird
I woke up like I licked Nikki's butthole
it was through the thongs
oh
my God it's a different episode we're
close yeah
um no I won't go from I'm like no I'm
still straight I didn't I don't like
that yeah you know you woke up he went
yeah
weird because she forgot that I lasered
but like every cat hair yeah I realized
that Tiff I've shared moments with her
at very like the like the uh the
quintessential stereotypical whatever
um uh the points in your life that
everyone always remembers like those
those those it was very strange like
like the first points yeah like when you
change yeah like everyone grows up
dreaming about their wedding well Tiff
and I had a beautiful moment at her
wedding yeah you know where we held
hands outside of the reception area yes
and I told her I was like I'm so happy
for you and I love you so much you know
and then
the next one was like
um so I couldn't make it to the
pregnancy announcement that she did for
everyone so she had to do it at my house
just with me yeah and it was like it was
almost like it kind of worked out
because this was like a sign in my life
where it's like look Tiff's here sharing
another beautiful moment in her life
that you can also achieve like these
core memories in life you know where she
got to tell me herself just with me and
her that she was pregnant and knowing
that what she went through before like I
cried and then another moment was in the
car in the in the [ __ ] beautiful G
wagon
that I was proud of her for all the
accomplishments that she's made in life
and then so my biggest fear in life is
that I will never be safe because
everything I've went through but I love
Tiff so much that I was so I felt so
safe that I took a nap with her in my
[ __ ] bed we've never done that
they're all about naps yeah right it's
just napping you know so Tiff so when I
mentioned my pillars in life is that
Tiff you are always my safe my safety
you know because you gave me all these
moments in life where it's like
um core memories that are safe and
beautiful and loving so you're that
because you are a very peaceful person
you know thanks yeah you really are
underneath all of anything that you feel
like you're too much of like at the at
the very bottom like you do just feel
like very peaceful yeah yeah it's so
sweet yeah you bring peace you're a wife
you're a mother you're a loving like the
like you
I tried your weird food that you made at
the first time
I tried your breast milk that's not
safety I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
you know like that's like [ __ ] some
instant infancy but yeah so you are my
pillar of safety which I I want and I
seek so bad you've like an
analogously I don't know
um you've drinking from her teeth yeah
yeah
like literally yeah I've only drink from
my mother before yeah you you know
you're the new mom yeah
I love you and even like your son now
Isaac like he's
like I he went to his homecoming so he
asked me just yesterday he went to his
homecoming yeah that was blowing my mind
because I remember like holding him like
a monkey like yeah this is like this big
or after I was in high school so now I
can't pick him up I know and then seeing
your eyes tear up I'm like Jess I was
keeping it together and I was like oh my
god oh man and then I look at Gina and
her eyes are all swelling oh my God
dude this [ __ ] I carried him in
the [ __ ] airport we were going to
Japan yeah but in like yesterday like
right before his homecoming like we were
sitting in my room he's like
Gina I'm really nervous and he's opening
up to me and then today after the
homecoming like right when I saw him
he's like he gets up and he hugs me
right away
like I'm like
dude you know yeah so it's like it's
going down Generations like you are my
safety and the family that I've always
wanted the peace I've always wanted and
so and Jess you are my pillar of
knowledge she's like the father and
she's the mother yeah it really is it
really is
it's weird you're like this super
feminine energy yeah and you're like
this masculine like thank you for that
limo yeah
it's true here's how you [ __ ] turn
your least yeah
it's [ __ ] hilarious this has under 10
000 miles
I've got a change of cooling on that
dude don't call the [ __ ] Honda
dealership go to the Mom Pop shop baby
take a picture of me next to my new BMW
thanks Dad
I could go
oh my God how much did you make
breakfast outside taxes on that
oh my God
oh
good
oh man so like whatever tip is like the
feminine safety Jess is like the
masculine stand up for yourself this is
what you [ __ ] do like I didn't grow
up with a dad like that's what I needed
my dad
yeah she eats out her mom though so
don't get too attached to this story
oh my God
Chase I ate your wife's [ __ ]
yeah so bye
[Laughter]
um so yeah Jess you were my pillar of
like knowledge where it's like you
taught me like all those all those like
red flags I had the intuition of like
all my fear like I was right I just
didn't feel validating anywhere I
couldn't I couldn't trust myself when
you were like [ __ ] yes it's real
[ __ ] believe it your intuition is
right and I had such a hard time
accepting that and you're the one who
taught me like you need to trust what
you feel on the inside you know like you
like you were you've always been so
[ __ ] brutal you've always been so
honest you know brutal yeah it's always
been so brutal and at first I'm like
this is kind of jarring yeah
yeah but after a while I'm like this
like this is the truest form of love
that you have that you give people you
know like you don't sugarcoat things you
tell them how what it is because you
love them so much because you've been
through so much [ __ ] in life you know
and it's like through you I've learned
to trust myself to like like I am
all the knowledge that I've gathered
throughout the years I have to trust
that and I got that from you and like
you you were like a father figure it was
really weird like it's very strange I
really know how to take this yeah [ __ ]
like he was like really you would make a
great lesbian okay great dad something
yeah
I'm gonna get you a Father's Day card
next year
but then it was also like I you also
were a pillar of like knowledge but also
strength because this [ __ ] did what one
or two years single me yeah for three
years no she had no sex for over a year
yeah oh yeah and then another one for
nine months yeah like she is like you
are just like all about self-love
and like growing yourself and just like
healing yourself which was like
incredible for me and I never understood
any of that and like you were like the
the
abrace of love that I needed you know
where like I was going through such a
[ __ ] crazy depressing period of my
life and I called this [ __ ] up and
she's like and she left she goes why are
you freaking out about that yeah
like this is normal what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you and I'm like sobbing my
eyes out
and she's like no you're fine like
you're good I'm like
so you like you've taught me so much
when it comes to just like
trust knowledge self-worth strength
you're like you were one of my pillars
of that which like dude if you told me
this three years ago these [ __ ] are
the ones that are still gonna stick
around I'm like yeah that's why I
believe in Soul contract so crazy right
I barely see my own best friends and I
see these [ __ ] more and I've learned
so much you know so you've played a big
part in like making me trust myself and
growing stronger as a person
I'm glad in this [ __ ] I don't know
Nikki's assistant
this is the family right yeah
knowledge this is the pillar of
acceptance
because I finally met someone that's
like me yeah to a T and it's like it's
weird like everything down from like the
way we act yeah our Hobbies our sex
preferences true you know where it's
like
yeah
you know it's like you want to see them
cheers
and that first uh the first time I ever
felt that was when um we talked about
our sex lives and our very first episode
of uh hey [ __ ] were uh Nikki and I
explained our sex lives what we prefer
and we both agreed we want to see the
eyes of God and nearly die when we have
sex she was like I punished me yeah for
my sins yeah the cord of an iron wrapped
around my throat is wow yeah it's like I
wanna I want you took me so hard I like
I panicked that I might die now I don't
want to forget that I exist yeah so the
table was like
all right and that's my first bonding
moment Nikki like you understand yeah
you get it and also like seeing your
relationship with Steve he goes hey
kiddo and I'm like
this is
amazing that's everything I ever wanted
or like this stupid [ __ ] like
grabbed a drink and said Nikki might
like this and brings it back to her you
know like so you are my pillar of
acceptance of who I am yeah on the
inside despite like what I put on the
internet how tough I am whatever you're
the stupid [ __ ] kid [ __ ] yeah I'm a
stupid soft stupid kid he doesn't think
I think he's a prince fan
I'm over here crying yeah you're right
he's done yeah
so it's like I I met this other person
that's like it's she's so like me it's
weird yeah we have the same everything
like Nikki you can't remember what you
do half the time me too yeah making you
collect all these weird things me too
she's like hey about the agent stuff
like can you help me with that I'm like
hey streaming so like okay
and I got her into streaming it's like
this weird
Soul contract where I'm like there's
another person like me and the then and
the the thing that solidified that was
the last time we filmed where you guys
were here but you weren't yeah so I had
to uh okay let me [ __ ] um I had to go
through a uh psychological evaluation
for a reality show that I might I might
be on I'm still waiting on word for it
it's very it's uh it's it's
um they they have to do this with every
show because it's reality show yeah if
you're filming with other people they
need to make sure that you're not gonna
[ __ ] murder them or kill yourself
afterwards you're not crazy so I have to
go through a whole entire psych
evaluation and like Nikki I remember
talking she went through this whole
process of realizing she has it what 80d
like in on the Spectrum yeah I had no
[ __ ] clue and then everything made
sense in my life like everything made
sense all the things that I mean I've
talked about it on the show before but
like I felt so broken so many times like
I didn't understand what was wrong with
me and when you were young you felt yeah
stupid so alone and like just like
walked into a room the light finally
turned on so you could see yeah and I
was like oh my God my whole life I
thought oh that makes so much sense like
yeah I get why they didn't want to be
friends with me but also like I wasn't
broken like it just was the different
way of thinking and like yeah so Nikki
has told me she's the first one that's
told me like Gina you and I are very
similar you should probably go get
tested and see and so I had to go
through like this whole psychological
evaluation you two were there because it
was the last time we were filming where
I had to actually like during lunch take
a 30 minute break to go and have this
psych evaluation with a psychologist and
he scored me like he's like all the
tests we like went through three stages
of testing where he he finally told me
he's like here's her biography you
scored really high on hyperactivity this
is why you couldn't focus in school you
like that's why you said C's get degrees
and you didn't want to do school anymore
this is why you did this this and this
and I told the girls afterwards I was
like
there wasn't anything wrong with me yeah
it's not that I didn't want to I
couldn't yeah yeah you know like I
literally couldn't and instead of
emphasizing your strength school was
like well you didn't do this part right
and this is the only part we care about
right yeah you suck yeah bye and then
like you it all of a sudden all made
sense and I went through a moment of
like resentment with my family where I
was like you guys
punished me for this one it's like
literally I just I literally could not
that's how my brain works and then like
I was like oh my God this is what Nikki
went through and this [ __ ] is just like
me you know like we we're like we're in
our own little ways because like we
didn't have a choice this is just how we
are yeah it's so funny too because like
your whole meme was that like you were
always late to everything and I was
always like super early but because of
the same reason like yeah
scatterbrain and so I got [ __ ]
hammered like my dad would just like
just [ __ ] the Mallet was like cast on
me every time I was like he's like on
time is late and early's on time and and
I was just like so scared of being on
time because it was like late that I
would show up so early to parties and it
was like not suspicious starting the
catering for them yeah and like like all
the things I was like hyper like anxiety
filled when we were like Eve like we're
supposed to be the airport two hours
early we're only an hour and a half
early now we're gonna miss the plane
yeah I'm so scared and you went the
opposite like the more authentic way of
like like hey we don't it's fine it was
wild because while I remember while I
was talking to him he bred out all the
things that I scored so high on it was
hyperactivity anxiety
paranoia and nervousness and everything
that he named off I was like
Nikki Nikki it's us it's it's us yeah
like she like and he also told me like
um
your your real personality Underneath It
All who you really are you're reserved
and shy what the [ __ ] are you talking
introverted yeah introverted I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about like
everyone knows I'm like this weird
[ __ ] Gremlin that's crazy he's like
no but when you get home you need quiet
time after being with people for so long
you just want to be by yourself and I
was like that's Nikki that's me and
again like that solidified Nikki is my
pillar of acceptance because I had to go
through this whole like acceptance
process of
[ __ ] you I put this image online for so
long that I wanted people to believe but
this [ __ ] the psychologists have
met me for 30 minutes read me like a
book first of all lower your voice yeah
okay like no one's supposed to know this
about me but he told me who I was and it
made so much sense gave me validation
and I accepted it and I realized Nikki's
the same exact thing so you're my pillar
of acceptance so it's like you're so
sweet I didn't want to be in like a
group of girls because I just don't like
the same around people I don't want to
be always easy yeah my own best friends
I don't see them and here I am thrown
into this podcast at first where I'm
like this is a financial decision that's
gonna be great and now I walked away
with the most core pillars that I needed
in my life and now it's coming to an end
but it's the best possible ending it
really is we're all like better dumbass
Game of Thrones ending they break your
[ __ ] heart yeah yeah and they like
wait I like those people now I don't
like them
no we like each other it's funny when it
comes to Full Circle where like back
then in JK Tiff had to like schedule me
it was so stressed out because I always
showed up late or I didn't know you were
gonna show up yeah but you didn't know I
was going to show up and now yeah now
Gina's the one with the full-time job
that shows up on time all the time and
I'm the one that's showing up late
that's like I was streaming like okay
yeah you guys totally like flip-flops my
call time tomorrow's at 7 30 in the
morning person yeah it's so weird I'm
dying of those cat ladies no I was
really shocked seeing you come in with
no makeup on or nothing I was like Nikki
I was like we're not even starting for
an hour mom like I was in the room what
happened to my little girl got here yeah
I was in my room I'm like do I use
someone brushing their teeth in my
bathroom yeah is that you yeah no I
forgot my two face
Vicky no just let it goes
you needed this so yeah you needed this
too yeah I needed this too I switched
like the end of my three years like I
started off as this [ __ ] nocturnal
gaming whatever that showed up late to
everything too I have a [ __ ] day job
on television girl I'm like you're like
an adult you have a boyfriend and I have
yeah so I started this message that's
public like a real one a real one I
started this podcast back then with a
boyfriend that I didn't go public with
ever because deep down I knew it was
gonna work out because he was
emotionally abusive yeah cheating
unavailable yeah unavailable it was a
terrible relationship you know yeah she
like I knew inside I couldn't go public
and you just knew this right off the bat
and it took me
quite some time for him to actually meet
you guys yeah because a part of me was
like kind of ashamed I was in this
terrible relationship and I was getting
out of or and I was going like before
that I was like I was going through this
[ __ ] awful relationship publicly with
STDs and crazy [ __ ] whatever and now
like three years later I have a day job
I'm very proud of that I'm literally
accomplishing myself yeah yeah it
incorporates everything that you've ever
loved everything I've ever loved yeah
the show that I've wanted to be on since
I was a kid yeah and
waking up early in the morning dude even
your environment when I come in here I'm
like does Gina still live here yeah wait
why is it why is your room why is your
bed made yeah are you sleeping on my bed
right now because it's made and
beautiful he throws up on it you know
like and then now I ending this podcast
I'm in a healthy relationship that I'm
like massively like in love with him I
feel safe I feel loved and he just
texted me an hour ago saying I booked a
surprise trip for us this weekend
I know you've been stressed out so I
booked this trip for you and this was
like the first significant other I
brought to you guys that I'm so proud of
you yeah yeah you did it
yeah I found my Steve yeah he's not a
real Prince fan yeah
like it's it's amazing like I I went
public with him I did a hard launch on
yeah I posted him on social so proud of
you yeah I'm so proud of all of us like
even though it's sad that this podcast
is ending like it's it's time like we
really had this Sisterhood of the
Traveling podcast yeah because like that
movie like they were all like so
different like yeah different lives and
like the pants fit all of them and like
they even had different body types and
it's like wow these pants fit everything
twice podcast with everybody it's so
weird and we've said this before too
where it's like if you told us three
years ago that at the end of this it'll
be us four yeah we wouldn't believe you
maybe it is like the Game of Thrones
ending oh yeah you know what I realized
we were all brought on as a secondary
not main ever yeah we're the main
characters we were well I think Nikki
was the main character but yeah
I call him yeah I love him well did you
come on first or Steve first uh me oh
yeah oh JK yeah yeah yeah and then yeah
in the podcast uh Nikki was like a first
tier yeah but she was first pick uh but
there's a lot of stuff we can't talk
about yeah
[Laughter]
yeah close your eyes Gina
yeah we were never like main you know
like I've known them a lot shorter than
I knew main crew so when you if you if
you were to tell us like three years ago
weird ragtag the final four yeah I would
never believed it it's like Survivor
where you're like whoa this is what I
was rooting for yeah yeah yeah
but um no I don't care we don't have to
wrap it up because I'm I'm like we
yeah because endings are always kind of
such sweet sorrow but I I think this is
the best possible ending for this
podcast and and it's not like completely
we're still gonna be friends so who
knows maybe we'll put out an episode
sometime in the future I don't know like
no promises or anything but
um like this is an ending so yeah and I
hope that like like sometimes I I'm like
oh some people in the comments like me
like get make friendships with each
other based off of
their Community yeah so I love you guys
I hope you guys all found some sort of
uh belonging and friendship that was
like the whole reason it started was
like wow like I never had a a girlfriend
group like this where everyone could
talk openly about things and we could
have different perspectives and and all
that stuff and um and then we got to do
it on a podcast and I feel like that is
what the audience or like you guys like
maybe connected with was just like
having people make you feel like you're
not alone out there wherever you're
whatever you're going through whatever
it's really weird like in the Moment
Like if you really stop and like stop
even thinking about the fact that we're
recording right now like yes as the
seconds go by like we're literally
living the end of this
the dad cries sometimes okay
you think it's always the moms
she's a big old softy the two hardest
members in this group are the softest
ones
yeah yeah
dude we can't open on this couch
they're going to and that's why I said
it's gonna be a two-hour episode because
I don't wanna I don't want it to end
there's still I feel like there's still
so much more
to say like
yeah there is and there always will
because we're we're like a moving
picture like it's always evolving it's
always changing it's changed so much in
three years like three years isn't even
a full High School experience guys yeah
we're about to go to the senior year
like that's true we're gonna more things
are like senior year and I quit
cheerleading and I'm just [ __ ] off
now yeah yeah
she was a cheerleader yeah wait I do
want to add something though before we
end
um no we're not gonna answer no no no
we're gonna end soon because my baby
needs to eat but um no what I did want
to add that I did forget is what Nikki
touched upon already which is you guys
the audience like
my the thing that kept me going the most
was actually the response that that you
guys gave to the podcast and also
meeting you guys in person and saying
like you know you guys are my favorite
part of the week and like I've learned
so much and like you guys are my big
sisters and the the stories that like me
I've personally shared that you guys
contact me about and you're like that's
helped me so much I'm so glad you talked
about that and all these things that
that just made this podcast so special
to me because I that was
the purpose that I had here because it's
just it's really difficult to to sit
here and then like you know share your
whole life and your whole like
vulnerable sides and your experiences in
your life but then to get the the
feedback that yeah we love that and it's
helping and we appreciate it and then I
don't know just made it
it made this podcast really special to
me and and really close and near dear to
my heart just as these girls are you
guys are too
yeah I really wanted
I think it's like what we realize I
think I think we all know this too is
that without the podcast we don't really
have a reason of flying and meet each
other yeah that's the underlying thing
yeah
yeah so it does feel like an ending in a
way high school's over
so it's like the this podcast gave us a
reason to keep
meeting up flying into wherever to see
each other you know
and without it it's like I don't know
when we're gonna see each other again
because our lives are so [ __ ] crazy
now
we are so busy everything's so busy and
it's like we just we'd still squeeze
just this last little bit out you know
but even if it's just for a weekend
where we don't even get to go eat with
each other it's just to film and hang
out in a room together yeah
but I will say like the most rewarding
thing is one growing our relationship
together and how close we got and two
seeing how this podcast has affected
people's lives like we went and did a
meet and greet
and the person that stuck up stuck out
to me was this oh like they were
beautiful like blue-haired yeah
non-binary like person just on the
Spectrum you know like just finding the
way through life and they went to our
meet great to meet us and
ask us questions and like they trust us
so much because of our podcast that we
meet together yeah and the podcast was
like us figuring out our own selves and
sharing it online at the same time like
in real time like like that's the like
the biggest part of it is that I really
was getting sick of YouTube culture of
like projecting some image that you want
to be online or you want people to see
you as and like how come we can't just
like show like some real [ __ ] like what
like people are actually going through
like what like who we really are and
then like this podcast was that and like
you got to see us evolve in real time
like and deal with [ __ ] in real time and
it wasn't always [ __ ] pretty like who
knows yeah yeah [ __ ] awful it was
probably really annoying for some
Sometimes some of it yeah and so I'm
really like I think all of us are just
really thankful for that and so feeling
like you know the ending of it even
though it's like it the timing feels
right
it it still is like bittersweet because
it's like
those
those like it's almost like having a
therapist that you your body knows that
you're gonna get a check in like you you
know you're kind of looking forward to
that and like you know that you're gonna
be able to like get some
some like relief or some like
um validation or like some like person
to like bounce things off of and then
now you know that's not happening
anymore and you're kind of on your own
you're like you flew the coop and you're
you have to fly on your own now it's
like that isn't it that's what it is
it's crazy how we started this podcast
off as hey we're your big sisters here
to guide you through life but this
podcast kind of guided us through our
lives yeah together so many so many
moments yeah yeah so many like
evolutions of ourselves yeah yeah so
anyway I hope that you guys
enjoyed your time here we love you that
won't stop
um
let us know in the comments
how you feel I guess I don't know I
don't know like be sure to subscribe
don't subscribe be sure to subscribe And
subscribe you never know
maybe we'll turn on a camera and yeah
share it with you upload like a a short
yeah
[Laughter]
dad have a kid
out of your pee hole anyway yeah leave
us a comment like let us know and you
know say hi to your fellow commenter
down below whoever they are just like
spread kindness and love each other and
make good choices and we love you
whatever part of your journey you're at
it's fine nobody [ __ ] knows so like
just be okay with that we love you it's
crazy I'm a little drunk
a little crazy but
thank you and
goodbye bye for now bye okay Casey fade
about like make it look like [ __ ]
Dramatics
get in here you stupid [ __ ]
[Music]
it's so weird
[Music]
though
laughs
[Music]
[Music]